e se a uma caixa que mudou o mundo
foi legal ea a caixa econômica vivida
por um é mero acaso e eu quero agradecer
a tecla vizinhos este palco efeito caixa
e não precisava sério eu ainda pensei se
ia tirar uma e simular uma contínua
sistema estão todas coladas em paetê
também agradeço as luzes em caladas
vamos embora de campeões sempre foi esta
caixa e quando era estudante do 4º ano e
econômicas 2 0 e conquistar o bi a que
em média 12 não ia lá ganhou pelo menos
eu pensava poderia ir comecei a fazer
pela minha vida a primeira coisa que fiz
foi organizar uma viagem de finalistas é
cuba 92 ao livro o fim do zinco mista
matar as crises e as coisas são as
expectativas o depois foi fazer um
estágio há uma uma técnica que é uma
associação jovens em estágios jovens
econômica gestão que fez um estágio
madrid em madri claro um bom time e
colocaram deram me lembro com soluções
uma régua um hábito e aquelas listagens
a 3 colunas que nunca mais acabava ele
uma cimeira paulo agora temos que
encontrar estou festa chique frase tal
que nós com beyoncé ganhou
quer dizer que estava a dormir numa zona
no bairro madre que era bilbao um bairro
como vida que o parceiro nova york até
achava da manhã muitas onu está
complicado em alguns momentos muito
complicados importados o que é que eu
fiz a pergunta e eu só vou dormir
producer flamengo possa dar uma volta
pela empresa que tem giro a micro
empresa e não deixaram eu fui aos custos
humanos
fui à comercial foi a área da produção
estava uma grande empresa multinacional
está engraçado e político do oeste facto
eu tenho que sair numa caixa e sair
grande coisa pensada uma caixa preta não
é perigoso eu escrevi ainda tenho medo
de 95
não é não é fácil mandar um homem
comenta 95 as chances só deixará pronto
normal e jae
e olha pra caixa de dormir aqui existe o
conheceu e me aqui escolhendo todo até
mesmo assim os percebem tudo eu espero
não está é é uma empresa tem de guardar
os arquivos epub surgiu surgiu giro
dirceu é fácil
obrigado deus por que não desistem de
uma ideia quer dizer muito mais partidas
do que está aparentemente não é que
querem plantar durant teve uma nova via
fonte
então nós os três colegas turma da
economia a olhar com um treino com mil
metros assim é pois um dos programas
mudanças assim filas acrescentou o
governo possa rever alguns pacientes por
causa da geada aplicá lo
psicologicamente que espera que passe
mais em que santo e esta oportunidade
chega à escola na altura nove pisos and
aos micro crédito originado a 0 e chega
à escola apoio de eduardo na
apresentação de uma coisa quer a
promoção da promoção de negócios anual
tem que fazer pela vida é e jô tv e um
está a fundos comunitários vem eu faço
as suas empresas que não apóia e tal eu
tiver a carteira não é fácil meter
mostre b em pinhais promoção é o campeão
dos povos
aí com ele sobre ativos do bb na
internet com os meus amigos pois o
depósito empresa vai rodar arquivos aqui
um esboço ea senhora dele lá no fundo se
espera venha falar comigo no fim da
década conferência que eu trabalho
outro lado não vou lá mil esteja sem
brincadeira e já está o nosso tempo até
lá fizemos lá fizemos um projeto há só
sabia isto era uma caixa e descobriu
pastas lá dentro não seria mais nada o
resto é tudo inventado essa caixinha
pensam que 92 93 9 neta atenção não
aceitam jogo eu escrevemos recordes
management história de arquivos e
e-mails em que aparecem 30 mil e um
tempo tanto faz
foi fascinante tempos desafiantes está a
fazer à estrada tipo linda de suza uma
linha de capital
folhetos em muitas foi que relatem os
exemplares quando lembrado quanto eu via
mau negócio da venda da unidade assim na
vida da república baixando a ter as
portas até campanha o cliente deixa umas
contas muito grande conforme a casa do
meu pai e filho estava falando uma
empresa até que apareceu primeiro em
primeira instância rapaz que está aí sim
vou pegar o libertaria que mandar na
vida liberdade e você vai me ajudar e
depois com o segundo terceiro quarto o
show 889 de arquivo
são cem pessoas em várias mídias
faturação ao longo de vida ea partir de
agora gostava de deixar são palavras têm
norteado a minha vida fácil digestão
a nota não pode ser empresários não
tiver o menino só estão este ano só está
o selo em simples começa por uma
estrutura de custos nas tic eo sr gastos
enquanto é que as matérias primas
produtos equipamentos e pessoal certo
pois o aumento das vendas
inventamos aqui uma margem positiva e
nós temos que justificar alguma forma
quando bastante com o negócio e é isso
que os 1700 pois nós nos unimos vai
transmitir essas coisas apertam cuja
yield os nilde
posso entender a estrutura do curso
querem ter o alder 4 é o leasing
correndo de painel e mandava onde uma
vez está a a pedra foi a estréia de léo
com um amigo meu foi da empresa comigo
então vamos olhar para uma loja vizinha
da hugo boss e vimos esse é o meu
objetivo nosso objetivo vitória só temos
nós só temos dinheiro e saber popular
correio e atender pouca boy para mim mas
sim isso e vamos até lá em cima tem uma
baixa até não tenho culpa pra provocar a
gente ainda tem o fato voz e tv a e é
bom que eu penso que estas coisas porque
a seqüência e minha qualidade enfim só
com muita facilidade
é importante eu acho que nós temos que
ter estas palavras de cabeça estratégia
é tentar entender revisar uma divisão
todos temos é uma vez de uma uma peça do
eu quero inox do antônio foi o saudoso
telê foi o inox e 11 rua e eu estava
seguro num funcionário público lotado
nem outra ideia já tem uma força tribal
em forma disse não se há muitas chegava
a profissão de finanças já tinha
qualidade mas está pra isso não dá
dinheiro não pode ser a nós portugueses
temos muitas idéias grandiosas até no
bom sentido da palavra mais pois nestas
oito e possamos pensar que está tudo bem
- empreendedores que existem
responsabilidades a responsabilidade é
fundamental o esforço envidado focos da
educação que nós temos que ser
responsáveis e quanto mais avançamos na
maturidade das nossas organizações mas
que possam virar tempos eu preferia uma
empresa que o funcionário
agora sou muito de uma decisão minha
maum - boa dependa de 300 pessoas são os
agregados familiares
depois tem marido que está muito feliz
com os outros candidatos média 35 anos
as medidas de forma mais ou menos as
suas vidas e tal é mais o contrário
mas ao contrário de execução mais
atrevidas nessas coisas
a responsabilidade é igual e patur sério
eu marcar o ataque e tô aqui a hora
certa e esse é o momento mais importante
da minha vida postou dependeu aqui com
vocês
ontem tive o stress
e que o hospital queria ver as duas da
manhã os ovos tudo eu tenho de estar
aqui
a responsabilidade também é isto é hora
de criar uma memória trabalho
simplesmente não posso ficar até o fim
do jogo agora para mais porque pode dar
um carrinho mais apoio e tal mas eu
tinha que vir a assumir esta
responsabilidade com sábias do ano
elemento constante e porque eu acho que
essas pastilhas anos ganhe vezes e vezes
e vezes vai batendo é às vezes faz com o
tinga fez falta em vôo com um salário
pois é talvez quisessem ser acessada 47
anos de vida já dá para ter uma
experiência muito interessante e ajudar
a instituição é pra mim o processo
contínuo de correção do erro
a empresa que menos erra ele é outra
palavra que infelizmente os políticos
deste país desvalorizar a sério o que eu
posso dizer é que a filosofia moral mas
os políticos têm escolha começou por
dizer simplesmente eu acho o nu bonito
disso eu passei e sincero que estava
perante um político ou modificar as leis
aqui advogados todo serviço não é têm
médico de família tenho de gato pronto
faz parte da vida de outras pessoas
sou a liderança eu escuto minha
liderança uma maneira muito simples nem
a frente as pessoas nem e traz ao lado a
lado
vamos contar uma coisa muito rápida
alguns anos atrás entre o colaborador
meu gabinete aberto dentro tem portas
abertas e sim em pauta em dia nenhum
problema mental e se encontra fora já em
cada porto o botafogo já volta a entrar
numa situação de cine e pensei fazer sim
ou sim ou sim ou sim
michael jackson cover é para ganhar
assim o bpi militar
eu fui autonomia king usa nos deus sabe
como é que nós pensamos então nos postos
já sabemos que vamos resolver as coisas
as pessoas são fundamentais só do lado
da contabilidade estupidamente então da
linha desgaste ajuda das empresas
aquelas que são boas tanto na parte dos
ativos
eu tenho um ginásio ou fruta e no dia da
mulher marly massagem uma rosa tempo
passo que em tempos ball equipa
a equipe toda não tenho vergonha disso o
técnico engenheiro 15 média tem não sei
que com dor de pai ou de graça explica
que o custo com 11 maio e terão de
informar e surgia sempre tanto gigantes
hoje augusto mateus joão ferreira do
amaral a constância ou um bom professor
e dirigente do banco de portugal
pronto não há negócio sem clientes a
gente tem paixão aí já passou está muito
na moda mas não há negócio sem cliente
bota tem que sempre pensar nisso aqui em
duas ou três questões muito importantes
na vida eu passei a melhor idéia do
mundo eu queria fazer nossos de power
eu adoro ir lá time frio sempre está aí
é que eu seja pai eu queria fazer uma
empresa para fazer aquelas máquinas tipo
expresso partida que os lados lá em casa
eu estava sempre aqui o bora será
cliente
outra palavra fundamental para quem está
cá há 22 anos
ramsey e em si a capacidade de resistir
votar reinventasse do paar e nestes
tempos desafiantes e não gosta da
palavra crise algumas palavras que não
existe não saiu não tomar uma empresa é
crise e é o união por último também
nível das empresas com lucro é
fundamental não entrar e ter um bom
produto tem uma boa solução
não temos lucro bottom line o único e
quanto mais longe o melhor é sinal que
somos bons
não tenho vergonha de pagar impostos
aqui tudo correr bem nunca perco é
criança cai vocês eu tomo discutir a
sério é tão grande que tirava com está
sentindo humor e boa disposição mesmo
novamente quantas vezes entrou pelo meu
gabinete e irfan paulo e do que é capaz
de conseguir vocês vão conseguir ser
livre
depois quando fechou postos de trabalho
e manter as coisas simples manter as
coisas simples que o pt incluiu e vai
ter uma máquina de lado não precisa ter
mesmo do poconé
a gente pode estar com a mão e faz assim
amalgama neto que perturbe 15
pronto agora mesmo a terminar tem uma
vida muito falha ao top box a ter
tropeçado no box sem dúvida faltou
futebol que sentimos tanto as minhas
paixões
o benfica facto de se ter um campeão
nacional pelo benfica e eu ter passado
ao lado de uma grande carreira no
basquetebol eu carreguei pra mim já foi
pra lá e depois apareceu mil têm agora
18 anos e que este lhe sou pai
o benfica é papo disse outra coisa
qualquer ao benfica olha te ver com as
coisas mais empregados
o presidente da casa do benfica de
palmela tem 82 gavazzi desde o chairs
cna é fácil ver com o site a pressão
fica nas mãos naquela unidade em
tashkent foi fundador da jc e que ajuda
sempre internet não em portugal tenha
precedência do porto ipp podem trocar no
facebook lança 'grande instituição
apresenta em 110 países têm sempre calmo
associado e promovam uma cidadania ativa
para todos também foi dirigente é de
vice-presidente és como nelsão 19
minutos mas com essa maratona
tenho orgulho em ser português acho que
eh pá a sério e nós percebemos
estamos buscando uma fora e por dentro
temos anticorpos conhecidos a malta não
gosta de luxo do início e isso o
ministro
os americanos são burros rio grande a
portugal legal e falar mal mas terá um
novo corpo não é pai todo o tempo e por
último há alguma coisa que tem portanto
costuma dizer se tenho que pensar e
trabalhar pra ela
e é isto o grupo abrigado